my father is a painter I took a lot of
art classes as a child and then I made
us sort of created my own little
bachelors at the University of Illinois
that included a little bit of film but a
lot of fine art and then I started
working as a graphics designer until I
took a little bit of a an internship at
a television commercial company and I
started to work on commercials in
Chicago and then was asked to do a
couple of films and sort of worked in
various capacities but always within the
art department and then I was asked to
be a decorator on a film which I I took
and I decided if I was going to make you
know going to make that a career I
should move to New York or Los Angeles
and I chose Los Angeles for other
personal reasons but anyway and then I
just continued to sort of keep building
that the most misunderstood I think well
two things one is that often people say
set designer which is another category
on films and those folks are also
they're the ones who design and do all
of the drafting so that's one one sort
of more semantic confusion and the other
I think a lot of people think we are we
do the same similar kind of work as
interior decorators with moving
furniture and draperies and such and
they don't realize the sort of scope of
what we you know it couldn't be an
entire village or it could be you know
it goes in past and future and and all
of that so it's much broader
you